let's say I'm an economist and I'm
curious about whether in general things
are getting more expensive or not and if
they are getting expensive
by how much so the way I'd approach that
is I would think of well what are just a
bunch of goods and services that the
average person would buy so I would I
would think up of I would think up some
type of basket of goods goods and
services and I would try to weight that
basket based on how people actually
spend their money so I'd say okay
40% of people's money on average is
spent on housing maybe another 10% is
spent on transportation maybe another
10% is spent on food and I would go out
into the market and I would see I would
try to take an average of what these
things cost and I would sample a bunch
of products a bunch of services so I get
a decent average of that so this was not
a this is not a this is not a simple
thing to do but I'm an economist and I'm
serious about trying to calculate that
and let's say that when I take that
weighted average of all of this stuff I
just come up with a number and this is
I'm not giving you the details of how
it's actually calculated but give you
the idea of what they're doing so I get
a number so I just you know to rent a to
buy or lease your average automobile to
lease your average apartment to buy your
average servings of food for for a given
family all the rest let's say I come up
with that costs and I'm making up a
number here let's say that it costs
$20,000 my basket of goods and services
just based on the way that I've waited
it and this is all happening in year one
so this is in year one year one now I'm
curious whether between year one and
let's say year five and year five
whether things got more expensive so
I'll take that same basket of goods and
services so basket of goods and services
and I'll try to figure out what is their
weighted average cost in year five and
this is a lot harder than it might sound
right now because the baskets of goods
and services change if computers get
faster do you use the same computer or
do you think about what the average
computer is which would
I'll be a better computer if most
people's TVs got bigger do you use the
same TV in year one and year five or do
you adjust for what is now the average
TV which is now bigger if houses have
gotten bigger on average you use the
same house you use the average house so
there's a whole bunch of areas here that
you can really tweak and these are
actually huge subjects of debate on what
is the actual increase in cost but let's
say that you're able to do this and what
you think is a pretty reasonable way and
you find that the same basket of goods
adjusted for things like technology and
all of the rest now costs now cost
twenty-two thousand dollars so your
takeaway from here is the same things
that cost twenty thousand dollars that's
the things that give you the same
standard of living in year one to get
that same standard of living in year
five you now need to spend ten percent
more it's gotten two thousand dollars
more expensive off of twenty thousand
dollars so it's gotten ten percent more
expensive so you as the economist what
you would say is as the way you've
defined it your consumer price index and
this is abbreviated with CPI Consumer
Price Index your Consumer Price Index is
up by by ten percent another way based
on the way you measured it and it
changes from country to country and even
within countries they change the way
that they do these baskets basket of
goods but by the way you've measured it
you would say that price inflation price
inflation has or you would say that the
price inflation has been has been ten
percent between year one and year five
or in general everything got ten percent
more expensive or you would need ten
percent more money to have the same
standard of living and in general when
people are just referring to inflation
so if you just see the word inflation
being referred to especially in modern
times they are referring to price
inflation this general increase in the
price of goods and services measured by
some type of basket of goods there is
another type of inflation and that is
monetary inflation monetary inflation
and they are related monetary inflation
is inflation due purely to an
piece of the money supply so this is
increase increase in money supply and in
general in general if this increase in
the money supply does outstrip kind of
the productive capacity of the country
it could very well lead to price
inflation but in general what people
measure when they talk about inflation
from one your next they're talking about
this basket of goods they're talking
about price inflation the other thing
that you'll sometimes see maybe in year
five maybe in year five someone says hey
I could sell you this house this house
so this is in year five I could sell you
a house and this house in year five is
is six hundred and sixty thousand
dollars is six hundred sixty thousand
dollars and someone might ask well what
what would be that price if we adjusted
it for inflation in year one dollars so
what they're saying is if you adjust for
how much how much value your money has
lost because if things are getting more
expensive that means each dollar is
being worth less you can buy less with
each dollar so when people say how much
is that adjusted for inflation in year
one money you're essentially saying what
amount of money with that house have had
to cost in year one that when you adjust
it for inflation when you increase it by
ten percent so that's the same thing
increasing by ten percent is the same
thing as multiplying by one hundred and
ten percent
or multiplying by one point one so what
amount of money would that house had to
have cost in year one that if I multiply
it by one point one I get six hundred
and sixty thousand dollars and we could
do a little quick math here to figure
that out so if we say let's say that I
don't know let's call it P P is the
price of the house in year one I'll call
it P one that x one point one times one
point one is going to be equal to six
hundred sixty thousand dollars when you
factor in the ten percent inflation over
these years now this is simple algebra
right here you can divide both sides by
one point one divide both sides by one
point one and we get
and we get these cancel out you get the
price of that house in year one sixty
six divided by eleven would be six now
you can work it out with a calculator if
you don't feel comfortable at but what
I'm about to do but this would give you
this would give you six hundred thousand
dollars if you work this math right out
here and you could figure out the
decimals and what we could do well I
think I think you get the general idea
here you can use your calculator I kind
of did this one in my head but the
general idea is a house in year one that
is $600,000 $600,000 if you factor in
the the devaluing of the currency or how
much how much more expensive everything
got in year five would cost six hundred
sixty thousand dollars so you might hear
someone say when they're talking about
inflation or they're talking about price
increases this house in year five is six
hundred sixty thousand dollars which is
equal to which is equal to $600,000
$600,000 in year in year one year one
money and it is an example of that you
know I live in a neighborhood where the
houses are have gotten all of a sudden
you know because I live in the heart of
Silicon Valley it's not a fancy
neighborhood by any stretch of the
imagination but the houses now are quite
expensive and we have neighbors who
moved in in the 50s and they say my god
I bought our house for $10,000 and now
people are selling these houses for so
much more and the reality is is that it
is true the house has appreciated but
ten thousand dollars in 1950 was
actually a lot a lot of money a doctors
and engineers did not make that much
more than then that much per year I
don't know the exact amount so the
reality is is that you actually have to
it you have to adjust money for the year
that you're talking about and you have
to adjust it for inflation so if you
believe this ten percent inflation
number hopefully people's incomes also
increased by the same amount so the same
person maybe with the same skills and
the same job who could afford the house
for six hundred thousand dollars in year
one could now pay six hundred sixty
thousand dollars for it and it won't
take an unusually large chunk of their
of their expenditure that it would take
the same chunk that it did in you
on so hopefully that clarifies things a
little bit and I'll in the future do
more videos going into the details of
inflation